the Dow staging a very modest come back
today finishing ahead 188 the S&P 500
was up 11 the Nasdaq surged 161 today
Susan Lee of Fox Business joins us now
from New York to talk about the markets
good evening Susan
good evening Bret small recovery from
three year lows there are hopes for a
big economic stimulus package from
Washington with a Federal Reserve along
with other central banks have been
pumping money in a train to help cushion
the financial fallout America's big
technology names leading the rebound
today Facebook Amazon Netflix and
Microsoft Amazon up but despite
confirming its first warehouse employee
testing positive for kovat 19 oil prices
meantime saw its biggest one-day rally
in history after President Trump hinted
that the u.s. might intervene in the oil
markets oil still down 60 percent on the
year as are the airlines and play maker
Boeing airlines are looking for 50
billion dollars in assistance from the
government Boeing is asking for 60
billion we will be helping the airline
industry we will be helping the cruise
ship industry we probably will be
helping the hotel industry will probably
be where jobs are created you don't want
to lose industries like this but there's
a loud criticism that says a bailouts
should come with limits no buybacks not
now not a year from now not 20 years
from now not ever because effectively
you're spending taxpayer money to buy
back stock and to me that's just just
the wrong way to do that some companies
as you know did stock buybacks and I was
never happy with that it's very hard to
tell them not to but I would tell them
not to I would say I don't like it for
that reasons well share buybacks it
usually lifts the stock prices because
they reduce the supply in the markets
and that with benefit
company executives who are usually
compensated with a lot of stock meet
time for small business 96% of owners
say that they are already being hurt by
the coronavirus in a survey by Goldman
Sachs while Bank of America says that
the u.s. is already in recession Brett
Susan thank you